I'm going to the bathroom.
Okay.
'Scuse me. 'Scuse me.
Megan, can you quiet down?
'Scuse me.
Megan, you're being loud.
'Scuse me. And 'scuse me.
Megan. Megan.
Megan,
what are you doing?
Andre.
Megan.
Andre, where are you?
Shh.
You shh.
I'm looking for my boyfriend.
Check your girl.
Okay, right.
I'm doing it right now, dude.
Megan.
Andre.
Shh.
Don't shush me.
I'm shh-ing you.
Andre.
Megan.
Andre: Megan.
Andre.
Megan, come here.
Andre?
Andre: Megan.
Andre.
Speaker 3: Shh.
Why would you go back
to where you were before?
Siri, call Andre.
Don't call me. Don't do that.
Megan.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry,
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Megan,
what is wrong with you?
What the fuck are you doing?
Andre, where are you?
I'm behind you.
Will you FaceTime me?
I'm not gonna do it right now.
You wouldn't be able to see me.
It's fucking dark in here.
I know.
That's why I can't find you.
I'm directly behind you.
Turn around.
Okay, I'm gonna turn around.
You didn't need
to announce it. Just do it.
I'm right there.
Fuck. Fuck. Fuck.
Stop yelling at me.
Megan, have you sustained
a head injury
or had a stroke
in the last 10 minutes?
What do you mean by that?
Megan-
Dude, put your phone away.
Yep, yep.
OMG, did you just hang up on me?
Yes.
I'm not talking to you, sir.
I'm talking to my boyfriend.
It's me, Megan.
Andre.
Lady, get out of here.
No, you get out of here.
I can go wherever I want.
I'm looking for my boyfriend.
Andre.
Come on. You can't be up here.
Andre. Shut-
... Get off me, mister director.
He's not the director.
Can you shine
this light on the audience?
I want to see my boyfriend.
Let me see something.
The light's in my eyes.
Megan, get out
of the projection booth.
Shh.
Don't shush me.
'Scuse me.
'Scuse me. And 'scuse me.
I couldn't find the bathroom.